you know we have to take a class to
learn how to go outside right has anyone
ever taken a self-defense class before
okay yeah that's a lot wow okay like 25
women the rest are dead okay
i took a self-defense class in my 20s
and i think we could maybe update the
tactics a little bit uh i remember the
tactics she told me i physically can't
even execute
she was like if your attacker gets you
on the ground gouge his eyes out what
the fuck
i can't even open a package from amazon
without getting a paper cut i can hardly
get a straw in a capri sun so
not sure this tactic is for me
none of it was pragmatic she said to us
never get in an elevator with a man
bitch have you ever had a job
you ever seen an office building before
it's basically a bunch of elevators full
of men
if i didn't get an elevator every time a
man was in i would just constantly look
like i was trying to get into a double
dutch game
you go okay i'll just quit
no
we have to be able to get into elevators
with men we have jobs now but i know
that's a very sketchy thing to do and i
know it could be dangerous so now when i
get an elevator with a man i just try to
make myself as unattractive as possible
so i just hit all the buttons
so that we're instantly in a long-term
relationship and he's completely
disgusted by me
i'm like you want me you got me
for 36 more floors and i want to talk
about the bachelor
i used to carry mace i don't carry mace
anymore because i find the packaging way
too patronizing when you try to buy mace
as a woman they try to sell you mace in
a pink bottle
but i'm trying to look scary
i'm trying to look menacing don't give
me something that looks like a toy at a
door of the explorer's backpack like
swiper
or the vibe i'm going for
a lot of my girlfriends talk about how
when they walk to their car they put a
key in between their fingers yeah but
they don't even make metal car keys
anymore okay the new car keys are those
little plastic little remotes so that's
a conspiracy thing about that shit for a
minute
the one weapon we have has been taken
from us
so now i gotta use my mailbox key
like an asshole
a little shitty wolverine
[Applause]
could you come forward a fucking inch
holy shitty wolverine
[Applause]
just kind of tickling my attacker at
this point
just kind of delicately caressing him
it's kind of bringing him to climax at
this point
you look like a villain in an 80s movie
it's just fyi